[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday April 25th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
Twitter's blue check marks have been
something of a status symbol since they
were launched to authenticate official
accounts for governments celebrities and
journalists but under new owner Elon
Musk that verification system has
changed last week Legacy verified
Twitter users began losing their blue
check marks and this change doesn't just
affect those who lose their checks it
points to a bigger shift for the
platform's future with us to discuss
that is wsj Twitter reporter Alexa
course hi Alexa glad you could join us
can you start by giving us a rundown so
far of what's going on with these blue
check marks I mean who has them who
doesn't and what do we know about why
there's actually quite a bit of
confusion about that right now but let's
back up a little bit last week Twitter
said it was going to remove check marks
from Legacy verified accounts so that's
users who weren't paying for
verification had been verified before
Elon Musk took over Twitter
but Twitter removed a lot of check marks
on Thursday but we quickly started to
see exceptions musk said he was paying
for some people's subscriptions to be
verified and get these other features
like LeBron James for example
and then over the weekend we saw even
more exceptions and blue check marks
reappeared on a bunch of celebrity and
other big accounts and many of them
posted over the weekend saying they
aren't paying and they aren't
subscribing so there's a lot of
confusion right now we haven't heard an
official explanation from the company
something else users of Twitter might
have noticed recently is also these gray
check marks can you tell us what those
are what are they supposed to signify so
the gray check marks are supposed to
indicate that an account represents a
government organization or government
official you'll also see gold or yellow
check marks for business accounts and
these are part of the new design that
that Twitter's been rolling out tell us
a bit more about the new design going
forward I mean what is Elon musk's plan
for these checks and for these new
different kind of account labels this is
arguably the biggest product change musk
has been working on since he took over
Twitter and the larger point is a shift
from this old system where you had
Legacy verified users who got these
check marks because they were authentic
and notable and it was a way to help
combat impersonation to a system where
you have to subscribe to get
verification in these other features so
we know some of these celebrities with
the blue check marks have said that
they're not paying for it but do we know
who is paying for the blue checks now we
don't know that exactly either Twitter
hasn't publicly said a number for how
many people have signed up we've seen
some third-party outside research
suggesting it's about 640
000 users today may be paying for it
thousands more have been gifted it
according to this outside analysis and
one study found that many users who
bought the check marks tended to have
conservative leanings talk about
cryptocurrency or were fans of musk
Alexa you mentioned that blue check
marks historically were this Mark of
authentication to say you know the
person whose name is associated with
this account is real or the business
associated with this account is real
since these changes have started taking
place has there been any confusion about
you know what is an official account
we've already seen some impersonators
there was an account pretending to be on
the New York City government for example
it was suspended fairly quickly but it
already had attracted some attention
we've also been watching this Saga
unfold with news organizations including
national public radio and the Canadian
Broadcasting Corporation they've stopped
tweeting because their organizations
were labeled government-funded media now
Twitter has since taken those labels
down and it's also removed those labels
from Chinese and Russian
state-affiliated news organizations
Alexa does this tell us anything about
Twitter's role as a platform for getting
news that's a huge question right now
for a long time news organizations and
Twitter have had this really explosive
awkward relationship where news brings a
lot of content to Twitter Twitter is a
way to get and share news I think some
of the important questions going forward
are will news organizations and
journalists find a new platform or will
Twitter have content that is as
compelling for users if more news
organizations say they're not going to
put their content on the platform
anymore and you know while we've been
kind of looking at The Saga of NPR and
the other news organizations that have
decided to pull back from Twitter I've
repeatedly had to say that Twitter has
responded with a poop emoji you cover
Twitter Alexa why is this the response
that journalists are getting so we reach
out to Twitter a lot I send a lot of
emails asking Twitter for information
comment on whatever's happening that day
and the typical press Twitter email now
auto replies with a poop emoji that's
been going on for about a month and Elon
Musk tweeted that this is an auto reply
for press inquiries now okay so an
unusual auto reply for press inquiries
what is all of this telling us about his
strategy for Twitter and kind of what he
thinks the future of the platform should
be well the rollout of the subscription
product is really important because we
know that Elon Musk has told his staff
that he really wants to grow Twitter
subscription business right now most of
Twitter's Revenue comes from advertising
and musk has said he wants that to be
more like 50 50. musk bought Twitter
about six months ago just wonder during
kind of
half a year on from that purchase if we
have a sense of just how things are
going you know like apart from just this
one subscription change it's been a
tumultuous six months we've seen some
advertisers pulled back we've seen these
kind of chaotic product changes we know
musk told staff that Twitter's valuation
is now about half of what it was of the
acquisition price what do you paid for
it Dad said musk has told staff that he
has a lot of optimism for what Twitter
can become he wants to grow Twitter into
kind of a super app with payments and
all these other great features turn it
into this hugely valuable platform
that's not you know where the company is
right now but that's what he says is his
ambition for it okay that's wsj's
Twitter reporter Alexa course great to
have you Alexa and that's it for today's
Tech news briefing for more Tech stories
head over to our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal thanks for listening
[Music]